quand vous étiez manager et vous avez
été un manager nerveux et que vous senti
que ça marchait pas
c'est pas ça c'est que ça marche mieux
quand on s'énerve pas ouais il faut
plutôt voir le l'autre côté avec ses
chefs a déjà parlé à des gens qui
viennent avec la boule au ventre le
matin qui disent gérant des
jantes en dit tout à l'heure quand vous
allez payer mathieu en poney ce sens
mais à quoi y'en a qui viennent la boule
au ventre est ici village vous savez il
ya un chiffre qui est bien on est 100 à
peu près là un peu plus soit 150 et 250
il y en a 15 qui ont ou vont faire un
burn-out non abbas et lui
il arrive aux bornes at on est numéro 2
mondiale derrière le japon il ya que le
japon qui nous barrent c'est vrai alors
on va expliquer on va est-ce qu'on peut
expliquer ce qu un burn out pour les
téléspectateurs alors un burn-out c'est
un jour où vous réveillez vous pouvez
plus rien faire grâce à l'expo s'explose
été ramassés on a buggé ouais c'est un
bug complètement et c'est pas une
maladie c'est pas le coc vite ça
s'attrape pas c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui fait qu'on ait épuisé
littéralement est en fait il ya la
meilleure arme contre le burn out c'est
le management sa et vous vous avez déjà
fin de damas n'ont jamais qui a déjà
fait un burn-out ici dit que la vérité
on enrage l'abri on est à l'abri mais si
mathieu non j'irai pas amer note mais
j'ai eu une année très difficile oui
vraiment vrai que beaucoup d'anxiété
aucune envie de se lever le matin aucune
envie d'elle au travail aucun plaisir
dans rien toute la journée semble
quand même allé faire un peu de sport
j'arrive quand même à j'étais pas voilà
j'étais pas allongé mais effectivement
d'avoir quelqu'un qui vous aide qui vous
donne un ou deux médicaments pour
essayer de vous le matin et les mieux et
c'est très compliqué expliqué parce que
quand ça arrive c'est les gens autour ne
comprennent pas et en fait c'est je
crois que c'est la pire des choses qui
puisse vous arriver parce que
effectivement l'intérieur évident mais
ça vous vous avez pris une leçon que ça
vous a permis de d'être mieux maintenant
affectivement rue saint-maurice à perdre
d'abord vous avez peur que ça revienne
donc vous faites attention à ça et puis
et puis effectivement vous relativisez
beaucoup plus de choses et vous avez
qu'une peur c'est l'anxiété ce que c'est
vraiment l'anxiété qui est le pour moi
qui étais le phénomène déclencheur de sa
c'est un mélange de pression d'anxiété
alors qu'on vous met ou que vous mettez
tout seul 1 de ce niveau dit rien mais
mais en tout cas voilà et donc c'était
qui fait que eba vous allez mal et un
sentiment de culpabilité qui va faire
que plus ça va mal oui plus on se dit
j'y arrive pas et donc plus je vais mal
et en fait c'est comme ça tout petit à
petit ça part en sucette